welcome to the simply learn YouTube
channel today's video is the second
video in our series of three meta
business Suite videos the topic for
today's video is going to be posting
scheduling and Publishing through the
meta business with but before we go into
that as usual I am Mark campman I'm your
digital navigator for this video and if
you like the video then please subscribe
to our Channel by clicking below and
before we start let me share something
with you first if you want to upskill
yourself or master your digital
marketing skills or land your dream job
in digital marketing maybe grow your
career become more uh more proficient in
digital marketing then you must explore
simply learn Cort of various digital
marketing programs they offer a variety
of certification and postgraduate
programs in collaboration with some of
the world's leading universities like
spj perju and meta as well through the
courses you will gain lots of knowledge
and work ready experience in skills like
search engine marketing strategies for
pay-per-click marketing Analytics and
many many other topics but that's not
all you also get the opportunity to work
on
multiple projects and learn from
industry experts working for top
companies and lecturers from top
universities so a fantastic collection
of digital marketing skills that you can
build up and after completion of these
courses thousands of Learners have
transitioned into a digital marketing
skill or a digital marketing role or
they moved on in their marketing career
so if you're passionate about making
your career in this field then make sure
you check the link below or check the
link in the um the the description below
and um to find the right program for you
that fits your experience and area of
Interest before delving into the details
let's talk about the pivotal role of the
meta business weed it serves as the
central control hub for businesses using
Facebook and Instagram and it's more
than just a tool it manages their entire
digital presence on Facebook and on
Instagram it consolidates all elements
of your presence into a unified
dashboard simplifying the management of
your ad account your pages and your team
collaboration then this streamlining
saves you a tremendous amount of time it
also minimizes complexity so you can
focus your attention on those business
matters that work for you best now in
the previous video we talked about how
to set up an account on the metab
business we and how to navigate the
dashboard and how to collaborate by
setting up other users in your your
account in today's video we're going to
look at another topic and that is the
topic of how to use the meta business
Suite to create and plan your posts and
your
stories so in the demo we're going to
cover the following topics we're going
to look at how do you create a post on
Facebook and on
Instagram how do you plan your content
and how do you use the content
calendar what are the not
notifications uh that you need to work
on and that you can set up and where do
you set them up in the meta business
Suite we'll look at the inbox the
messages and comments and how you can
automate responses and then finally
we'll dig a bit deeper into the stories
how can you create stories using the
meta business
Suite there are many social media
posting and planning tools like hot site
like Soho social buffer Sprout social
they all work really well and they allow
you to schedule and manage posts on your
social media channels on Facebook on X
on Instagram and many other platforms
however there are various reasons why
you want to choose the meta business
suite for your posting over other
platforms first of all meta business
Suite is developed by meta
ensuring a seamless integration with
Facebook and Instagram and making sure
that you can leverage all the
functionality in Facebook and Instagram
within your posting in The Meta business
Suite also content published through the
meta business Suite may have a slight
advantage in the algorithmic reach on
Facebook and Instagram basically
Facebook will reward you for using meta
business s to post your content by
giving you a wider reach for your post
it also also gives you access to new
features and updates within Facebook
yeah and Instagram faster than other
tools like hoot
Suite they offer better security
measures and compliance with platform
policies within the meta business suite
and direct access to support is
available within the meta business Suite
as well so that will expedite your
issues
resolution so Facebook the publishing
facilities within the meta business
manager they are designed specifically
for Facebook and Instagram so that makes
it much friendlier easier for you to use
than some of the other
platforms good so let's delve into the
posting and Publishing on Facebook and
Instagram let me go to the real life
dashboard so here you see the
dashboard and let me first show you how
to um create a post there are various
roots that you can use to create a post
there is here the create Post Yeah you
can also go through the planner you can
go through the content so there are
various ways that you can get into but
let me show you the create post uh the
simple approach I'm clicking here create
post and I'm then getting to the basic
screen for creating a post yep so here
you see all the elements that you need
to do yep so first of all you're going
to specify the platform that you want to
post and I've selected here Facebook and
Instagram I can then add the photo I can
use a template and here I can use
specific text and here I see the
scheduling options I can set my privacy
settings and here you see the preview
either in the Facebook feed or in the
Instagram feed so I'm going to add a
photo I can actually upload from the
desktop or add from the file manager
we'll look into the file manager in a
bit but I'm clicking upload from desktop
and then here I can go to let's say for
Russia picking this photo the photo is
now being uploaded and here I see what
the post is going to look like then here
I can add a text and I can say
winter
promotion yeah in R for Russia I see
here how the text is being added yes so
I can completely see how the post is
being set up I can add all the stuff
that I can add on Facebook as well yep I
see the Facebook feed preview I can go
for the Instagram feed
preview I can look at the desktop and
the mobile version so it's a fully
featured um posting platform within the
meta business piece yeah so now a few um
things of course before finalizing the
post take advantage of this preview
feature in the business Suite yeah so
make sure that your visuals and your
caption displays as intended and that
there are no formatting issues so making
sure that the post looks exactly like
you want it to look and then when you're
happy with the post you click either
publish or you can say finish
later
so I can also schedule the post yes so
I'm clicking here publish and then the
post will be published this may take a
moment or you can set here your
scheduling
options yeah so you see now that the
post is
published so but I actually I'm I'm
going to delete it in a minute because I
don't want this post to go live yeah so
if I can want to create that post I can
also say the scheduling options and I
can set a date and a time for my post
okay so that gives it to you in a
nutshell and what we're going to do now
is let's look at this file manager in a
bit more detail the file manager is a
tool that metab business Suite um has
put together to allow you to add and
organize your assets for your business
account yep assets like your photos like
your ads like videos Etc so with file
manager you can collaborate on files and
folders you can assign access to
creative assets and you can plan your
content more efficiently so you can
manage your image and video files for
use in your posts or your stories or
your videos you you can upload multiple
assets at the same time for later use
you can create albums to organize and
access your creative assets and you can
share your assets with other people in
your team so how do you access the um
file manager you can go here to all
tools and then within the all tools you
see here file manager so click on that
and that takes you to your file manager
where you can create folders and where
you can add sort of creatives in your
folder so if I go to this folder and I
can uh check the folder and here you see
one of the um the assets that I've added
into this file manager clicking here I
can straightly bring it into my creative
posts yep so I can use it to create a
story or I can delete it I can look at
my folder setting yeah here you can see
which people have access to the folders
I can assign Partners to the folders I
can edit these folder permissions so
very useful tool and particularly if you
have lots of assets for your products
then this can be a very helpful tool in
managing those
assets so if it takes me then a step
deeper to the content Tab In The Meta
business site as well yeah that is where
you can find all your published and
drafts and scheduled posts including
your reals your video posts your stories
your photos and your live videos you can
see what is published what is scheduled
what is draft what is expiring what is
expired yeah you can add your reals you
can even export the data and still still
access to your create post or your
create
real here you can see the date published
of the post you can see the status of
the post if it has been boosted or not
yeah if it what's the distribution for
the Post how many you see then some some
statistics on the posts as well and
we'll dive deeper into the insights
later in the third video but here you
can already see The Impressions the
reach the play s and very important the
reactions the engagement that you had on
the different posts so very useful tool
yes so you can within this tool you can
manage your post you can create posts as
well and there's also access here to
your ab tests if you want to test posts
on their uh their effectiveness you can
also within the content and I like that
you can see your feed and your grd yeah
so here you see your Facebook feed this
one is that I've just published although
I've deleted it as well but um yeah and
here you see your Instagram feed you can
see your mentions and your tags so it's
almost like managing your feed as well
and here you see your collections within
your file manager like Facebook photos
playlists and series that you've can
created
very useful tool that um you can use to
manage your content together with the
file
manager right so that concludes the
posting element yeah let's now go into
the next level of managing your posts
and that is through the planner the
planner can be accessed by clicking the
planner button here on the menu in the
metab business Suite dashboard so if I
click on the Planner yeah you can access
your kind of your content dashboard and
within this dashboard you can have a
total overview of what you have posted
and what you're going to
post and you can see some basic
information about your different posts
as well yeah and it's a very useful
visual tool to plan your content and to
plan ahead of your content so you click
on the planner tab as I mentioned yeah
it also features this calendar that
helps you plan schedule and visualize
what count content you want to share and
when you want to share it you can also
use this calendar to coordinate your
content with holidays and special events
what is going on and you can also use
use it to manage your creative access
your creative
assets yep so here you see the goals
that you can specify you can add goals
yeah so we for instance I want to
increase reach you can specify that for
a specific period and then here you see
how you Faire against reaching the
objective of the goal that you've set
there's also the moments now
unfortunately moment does not work in
most of the markets currently it's only
working in the US so here you will see
what sort of events are coming up like
holidays National events or you can
specify your own events and that's
always good with your posting of your
content because you can then relate your
content to the events that are relevant
in your
Market so you can look at your content
type yeah so you can have all your
content showing in your calendar or you
can look at your stories your reals or
your ads and here you can specify set it
by week or by
month and it gives you as I said earlier
a fantastic overview of what you have
done and what you're going to do it also
and that's what I really like about it
gives you a um gives you kind of a a
library of the posts that you have done
in the
past so the content calendar yeah is
very important it's also called an
editorial col calendar it's used by the
marketing team to plan and schedule your
content across your Facebook and your
Instagram so it serves as a road map for
your social media marketing strategy and
it makes sure that you will be
consistent and
cohesive with your
posting yeah and it's a very important
tool that marketing teams are using some
key elements of your calendar yeah it
outlines the type of content you plan to
share that's number one yeah it helps
you scheduling it includes the specific
dates and times for when your posts will
be or for when your content will be
published
yeah so you can schedule it forward as
well what are the posts that you are
planning in the coming
months good content calendars have an
integration of your different social
media
channels yep so that is very useful
because then you can select and show the
post for each sort of um channel that
you're using the calendar often includes
themes or topics for postings yeah so
you have a diverse range of content that
you're scheduling there's also alignment
with your campaigns in your content
calendar so it aligns with your broader
marketing campaigns or events so your
social media efforts they're really
contributing to it to sort of achieving
your marketing objectives good content
calendars they have collaboration
features so multiple members can
contribute or review so you can
coordinate your efforts across your
posting and by pling planning and
scheduling your content in advance yeah
it's just a matter of efficiency it
helps streamline your content creation
and your posting process and finally a
good content calendar helps with the
communication within your marketing team
so everybody is aware of what is being
scheduled what posts are coming and they
can plan their tasks
accordingly now that we looked at the
publishing and planning side of your
content and your posts let's look at the
notifications a very important part of
your Facebook and Instagram presence
unfortunately metab business Suite
allows you to receive
notifications related to your Facebook
and your Instagram business accounts
whether you get those all messaging or
whether you get them on your email so
what are notifications they are kind of
alerts or messages that inform
people yeah and it's mainly you of
course and your marketing team that are
working on the Met business Suite as
well about specific activities updates
or interaction
with the meta business weed
platform so what are the features of the
notifications in the meta business Suite
so here we go into the notifications
button that we can access through the
meta business Suite menu so click on
notifications yeah so first of all you
can customize your
notifications yeah so you can customize
the notification preference
based on your settings and your
priorities you can receive realtime
updates on relevant activities so that
keeps you in the loop and you can
explore the advanced notification
settings and in the advanced
notification settings you can tailor
your notifications based on specific
activities so you're getting prompt sort
of um messages about events that are
critical to your
business so here's the overview yeah so
here there's no new
notifications here are the other
notifications that are coming in these
are notifications from within your um
within your Facebook or your Instagram
here you can filter your
notifications yeah so you can have uh
set for Action needed message reminders
comments
recommendations notifications only for
Facebook or Instagram or your business
account here you can set Market read and
here you have the settings of your
notification and here you can
specify what notifications you want to
have and most notifications that will go
within your team your marketing team
will go through
email yeah so you can set notifications
for Facebook for um yeah for your page
for messages for comments for
announcements for
suggestions other Communications like
tags like shares and here are you can
set your business email notifications
for business permissions roles ad
accounts pixels and more yeah so that
goes um quite
deep so let me dig a bit deeper in the
type of notifications you can get via
your email that could be activity alerts
yes so they include alerts about
activities on your business Pages like
new likes comments or shares there can
be page insights so users may receive
notifications about insights and
analytics related to the performance of
the business page there could be alerts
on messenger interactions yeah so if you
use the messenger for customer
communication you may receive
notifications about new uh customer
messages could be um alerts or
notifications around ad campaign
updates so information about your ad
performance the budget charges or budget
changes or other AD campaign related
events that could be page management
alerts yeah important action or changes
related to the management of your
business page there could be platform
announcements from
meta yeah they may use the notifications
to in uh communicate important platform
announcements updates or
changes there could be notifications
related to security and finally
notifications around events and
reminders so very useful tool to use
important to make sure that you set the
right
preferences and make sure that you check
it regularly yeah what the notifications
are that you are getting
in besides the
notifications another important area is
your
inbox and within your inbox you have
your messages you have your comments and
your automated responses
so you can access that by clicking on
the inbox in your
menu yeah and meta business Suite they
offer several
features related to this communication
and engagement within your inbox they
enable your your business to effectively
manage your communication and your
engagement on Facebook and on Instagram
so a centralized inbox is very handy
that you you can have that because it
streamlines your responses and it makes
sure you and you sort of you respond
timely and
consistently with your
audience so if you look at the menu your
centralized Hub as it were this is where
you can manage your entire inbox you can
look at just the messages messenger
Instagram yeah on WhatsApp Facebook
comments Instagram
comments yep so here you see all the
messages whether it's unread if it needs
followup you can label it here is the
filters that you can specify here you
see the people that communicate with you
then here you see the community or the
sort of the communication that is being
done so really useful if I go here to
myself yeah what you see for the users
as well that have have enabled that you
can see their profile details as well
and you can set a label could be like a
new customer or a prospect you can add
labels yeah so that can be like a mini
sort of CRM system to manage the
communication with your prospects for
instance yes so that is the um the inbox
so and that is sort of the um the the
the dashboard that you have for your
inbook box so again we'll look at your
messenger yes so that's all the private
messages that you receiv received within
your Facebook and Instagram business
account the
comments yeah they focus on comments
that you get within your Facebook or
your Instagram business page so this is
where you can efficiently Monitor and
respond to comments so that can really
help you with developing your engagement
with your
audience so what I really like about the
inbox is that you can also set up
automations so you can set up automated
responses to messages messages that you
received within your um within your
inbox so they can be customized and
triggered based on specific keywords
based on Greetings or specific questions
that you get and they are very useful to
provide instant replies and managing
manage your customer inquiries
efficiently so they can be
configured yeah to acknowledge a receipt
of a message or provide basic
information or guide users to relevant
Source Sant relevant resources so let's
have a look if I click on the
automations
yeah then here you see there is
basically a um a library of automations
that you can set
up and some here you can see the ones
that you have already set up and that
you have activated so for instance I
have already activated an instant reply
or I've activated identify unanswered
messages yeah my away message is not on
or I can create an Automation and then
here you see the library of kind of
templates that you can choose from you
can greet people yeah share information
organize messages send a confirmation or
followup yes
so you start with templates so it is not
a huge library of templates that you
have but at least it allows you to to
use to look at specific um sort of
common sort of scenarios that you can
can face and you can set sort of
alterations for
those right let's go back and let's go
to the final demo in this video and that
is take a bit of a deeper look into
creating
stories so stories of very Dynamic and
engaging format for content sharing yeah
because of their temporary nature and
their interactive features and Prime
placement don't forget that yeah it
makes them a very valuable tool for
businesses that want to enhance the
engagement on their social media
presence and connect with their
audiences and make the content more
authentic and immediate
stories also help increasing the
visibilities because they appear at the
top of a user's feed so that provides
Prime real estate for visibility and it
makes it more likely that users will see
your content and engage with your
content yes so and there are lots of
Engagement opportunities as stories are
designed to be interactive with features
like polls questions quizes swipe up um
links yeah and it connects with your
audience in a much more engaging
way
so let's have a look at the stories how
you create
them yeah so here we say create
story yeah what I like about stories is
that they provide the opportunity to
share kind of raw unfiltered content to
your users so you can give your your
followers a behind the scenes look at
your business or the personal life and
makes your posts a lot of lot more
authentic yeah so you can build stronger
relations with your uh with your
audience there's also a thing like fomo
as we call it it's the fear of missing
out because of the temporary nature of
stories they typically last for 24 hours
it creates a sent of
urgencies yeah so you encourage users to
check your stories regularly because
they feel I don't want to miss anything
that you are um that you are posting in
your
stories it's kind of known that people
for instance on Instagram will spend
more time in the stories than in the
newsfeed yep and businesses use that
they businesses know that stories yeah
their algorithm they often prioritize
stories making them more likely to
appear on the users uh feeds so and
another big feature of stories by the
way is the highlights feature
particularly on Instagram so you can
create story highlights which are
collections of past stories that you can
feature on your profile permanently so
that is a fantastic way to Showcase
important information or key aspects of
your brand I always say it's like the
menu of your website yeah you can
actually have that in the highlights on
your
Instagram so and finally the power of
stories is also that they offer
advertising opportunities both in
Facebook and in Instagram so businesses
can use that to reach a broader audience
and promote products or
Services of course it's not as user
friendly as on the mobile but at least
you have some functionality on the the
um that you can have on the mobile as
well so add photo video we're going to
go in the same photo here
open yep so here you see the photo and
here you see how the story is being
uploaded yep so you can then add your
text as well so you can click
edit yep so here you can see I can crop
I can text or I can add stickers so
let's add text so the text will be um
I'm going to put it here yeah
so uh
winter
promotion yeah put that
here and then we have text is blue or
text is red let's make it
yellow here we go font I can
choose yep and then I can say let's
stick with that and here I can say I'm
going to add a sticker as well yes so
you have a whole library of stickers it
is again not as advanced as you have on
the mobile but at least you can do a bit
on the yeah so then I can click apply I
can add my multiple um media of
course I can schedule it I can share it
straight away or I can schedule it and I
can set my priv settings as well so
really good functionality within the
meta business Suite so create the
stories here or create them on Facebook
or Instagram itself on the mobile but at
least you have some functionality on
that here as well to Leverage The Power
of the
stories there are two additional items
in the all tools that you need to be
aware of that can help you with your
content creation and your content
planning if I click here on all
tools then in the menu you will see here
sound
collection sound collection is a
fantastic tool to enhance your video and
audio content which with free music or
sound effects that you can use in your
posts and it's a hidden sort of Secret
In The Meta business Suite but it gives
you a great great collection of hundreds
of sound files that you can add to your
videos or your um your photos or your
your stories and there you can sort by
genre by Mood by duration by vocals by
tempos you can add it to favorites there
is as you can see here over 10,000
13,000
282 soundtracks in there that you can
can use and they're all free of charge
so there's tracks there's sound effects
and it is very handy little tool that
you have in the meta business manager so
the other one that I want you to be
aware of if I go back home and back into
the old tools is the collaboration
Center so here in the manage you see
your collaboration Center and that is
where you can sort of structure your
Partnerships with brand
and with
influencers so you can sort of assign uh
Brands and partners that you want to
collaborate with on your posts and with
the whole growth in the influencer
marketing uh area this is a very useful
part that you can um can you can set up
to manage those
relationships that brings me to the end
of today's video now let me summarize
both posting on The Meta business Suite
involves logging in navigating to the
create post button select a platform
Facebook or Instagram or both add
compelling visuals and captions include
relevant hashtags preview the post and
choose to publish immediately or
schedule for
later using the publishing facilities in
The Meta business we
ensures a streamlined approach to
content creation and content management
and you leverage the native integration
for potential algorithmic advantages
basically you will reach more people
when you post directly through Facebook
and Instagram by using the meta business
Suite also by using it you can access
the latest
features you can on the you utilize the
enhanced security and the simplified
interfaces making it a valuable tool for
your social media posting across
Facebook and
Instagram so that's a wrap and look out
for our third video in this series on
The Meta business suite and in this
video we're going to cover the insights
we're going to cover commer and we'll be
talking about how to use the meta
business Suite to manage your Facebook
and Instagram
advertising if you want to know more
check out the other simply learn courses
and of course if you like the video
click the like button below or click the
Subscribe channel to uh subscribe to our
Channel and join our learning community
on YouTube thanks for watching and I'll
see you at the next video staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upscaling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here